hey guys I had a few problems with this
video since the official mr. robot
channel uploaded a bunch of clips from
the episode this caused my video to get
blocked for play match violations it's a
lot of magnetic system so even though
falls most likely under fair use for me
to use clips and a review I just decided
to pull out the volume for the scene so
I don't have to wait for an appeal or
redo the whole thing from the beginning
in the future I'll figure out something
and you know whether it's even useful to
have clips or not since you know with
this one I lost three days of having it
blocked worldwide and that's not good
for me so I hope this won't take away
from the video too much but I wanted to
get something out before the next
episode is released hey guys it's Pete
and another mr. robot episode is come
and gone it's another solid effort and
when you get some more insight and
answers to some really big questions
this time so this will be my season 2
episode for recap and review and let's
get right into it we start off with a
flashback to Elliot's apartment it's
actually a tease because it looks
similar to the knockin scene at the end
of last season but it turns out to be a
different knock on the door this time so
while it isn't the answer we've been
looking for we do get to see how things
got rolling with the v 9 hack in the
first place
Darlene shows up out of the blue and it
seems like Elliott doesn't want her
there Orly at the very least he isn't
interested in seeing her as he's trying
to brush her off she says the title of
the episode which is in it 1 this is a
Linux command that basically closes off
the system to a single user access she
mentions she wouldn't use that term if
she didn't mean it and tells him that
she really needs him to hang out with
her
the two get comfortable and start
watching an old movie from their
childhood the careful careful massacre
of the booze huazi we find out that this
is where eff society mask comes from the
one that Darlene was wearing when she
came to the door and it obscures a
really important part of the scene at
the same time the masks origin and the
movie are really cool but what stands
out to me most about this is we see a
side of Elliott we've never seen before
despite his reluctance at first we find
out that he really cares for Darlene and
has a traditional brother-sister
protective sort of relationship despite
all of his loneliness and social
awkwardness at least when it comes to
Darlene he can step outside of himself
somewhat he asked her if she's still
having panic attacks and we find out how
he ended up seeing Kristin in the first
place he tells a story of his last job
where he was working in
his he was basically discovering all the
holes in a you know his employers
platform his job was to keep going until
it was hacker-proof
and you know he says they were they were
not that good so he was keeping all of
his co-workers at the office and they
were trying to go home for a holiday
weekend they end up lock him in the
server room where he falls asleep after
a few hours and when he wakes up all the
servers are destroyed
he doesn't remember doing it and when he
goes to court the judge sends him to
therapy for anger management she asked
him about their mother which leads to a
short discussion about their father and
how Darlene wishes she could remember
him better Elliott goes to the closet
and pulls out the mr. robot jacket to
show her she asked him to put on the
mask from the movie and we watch as he
lays out the plan for so I had the clip
in this section but the video got
flagged for playing match which I guess
that means that the background music is
causing a copyright problem from the
automatic checker and since I don't know
how long it'll take to dispute and you
know whatever I just pulled it out so in
the scene Elliott puts the jacket on
with the mask and says maybe he should
take the job at allsafe so that he can
become a Trojan horse it's interesting
because he lays out the the hack exactly
as it goes down and he stresses at the
end that the hack won't be that hard the
actual hacking part that the hard part
will be after he says that that you know
they'll have to continue so that they
destroyed the credibility of ecore long
after the actual hack happens at the end
there we get an insight into what
Darlene has been up to in season 2 and
overall we get an idea of just how
coherently the initial plan was laid out
by Elliott it really puts into
perspective how his mental state has
deteriorated over the time we got to
know him while he was you know working
at allsafe we get back to present time
and Darlene has come to visit Elliott at
their mother's house it appears she
wants to tell him about Romero but
instead he tries to talk her out of
continuing the plan she's a little
worried about his mental state so she
just never brings up the you know the
fact that Romero had been killed he
tells her that you know what she's doing
is too dangerous and they more or less
go back and forth without either side
backing down again we see this loving
and caring side of each character which
was unnoticeable throughout the first
season kind of the big thing here is
that she tells them they have something
big planned for the bailout vote in DC
which is coming up you know that would
be the big bailout for the
the banks wear their hat you know where
their hack was concerned and Elliott
says they're on the other side of
something they never signed up for at
this point she loses her patience
reminds him of what he said adore in the
beginning and tells her and he tells her
that it wasn't him that said those
things that it was mr. robot
conversation ends with Elliott wondering
what she is keeping from him and Darlene
saying that maybe she needs mr. robot
not Elliott after all Thomas at the
arcade with a lot of FBI agents we find
out the connection to the FBI list that
she had you know photographed at
Romero's in her phone when she tells
another agent that on each page was the
name of one agent from the New York
office that interviewed Gideon inside
the arcade she's met with a bunch of
skepticism by the other officers that
she's talking to about the connection to
the hack when asked what hard Evan she
has uncovered she presents a shell
casing that they found behind the duck
hunt type game I think it was called
Mallard hunter we see that joanna is at
the parking lot where Elliott woke up in
Tyrells car after his three-day blackout
post hack she has the attendant in the
car and he looks spooked about being
interviewed repeatedly by law
enforcement seems a little bit baffling
to me for a couple of reasons and it
raises some questions first why does
this guy have information to hide what
does he know about the three days that
we don't and why is it worth so much for
Joana to pay him and go out and
personally reassure him that there's
nothing to worry about second what role
does the security detail play with
Joanna at this point were they privately
hired to you know buy the wellick sin
the first place I was under the
impression during season one that they
worked for Ecore but in their
conversation we find out she's running
out of money because her husband's
severance package hasn't come through so
other than the agents name which I know
is mr. Sutherland I can't really find
too much out about this guy let alone
who he actually works for let me know in
the comments if you have any info on him
and who you think he works for or what
his deal is we get a quick shot of
Angela outside the Ecore office
listening to the positive affirmations
on her headphones we see the two guys
from the dinner that she had with price
being escorted out in handcuffs while
the voice in her headphones says all my
dreams are coming true right now we cut
to Elliot and Maury playing chess at his
office ready beat Elliot and tells him
he needs to work on his game when he
tries to start over ray tells him
instead
repeating his mistakes to take the board
home and play himself to practice they
go back and forth which leads ready to
say that Elliott needs to unburden
himself and that anything he tells him
will stay inside this room this prompts
an appearance from mr. robot who
threatens to jump off a building if
Elliott does any such thing for the
first time I'm not really sure if Frey
is trustworthy they are definitely
playing him in that light but given his
shady dealings it's a little bit hard to
tell if he's trying to get some leverage
against Elliott so that he can get him
to help out with his Bitcoin problem in
the end Elliott doesn't tell him about
the hack and he says that Elliott needs
to chess board more than he realized
angel isn't is in another bar talking to
the lawyer from the Washington Township
lawsuit and there's a news report about
the E Corp insider trading arrest
playing in the background find out the
lawyer played a part in having them
arrested and Angela lays out what she
thinks price is up to with her she says
he is creating leverage and says they
need to look over the arrangement or the
agreement drafts to find out what is
missing back in Elliott's room mr. robot
challenges them to a winner-take-all
match of chess the stakes through
whoever wins gets to take over and do
whatever they want completely if Elliott
wins he can confess and unburden himself
but if mr. robot wins he he will take
over Elle and Elliott will exist in
complete nothingness there's an
interesting proposition as nothingness
is a sort of relief but the price that
he has to pay is incredibly high Elliott
is then in Krista's office thinking
about taking the offer when she asked
him if mr. robot is the only person he
interacts with he lies and says yes
Chris Krista asked to talk to mr. robot
and this leads Elliott to pouring out
the details of just how unraveled his
mind is she tells him the game he is
thinking about playing is very dangerous
because he is talking about destroying a
part of himself basically whether he
likes it or not
that's part of who he is it's a great
observation but Elliott isn't willing to
accept it he acknowledges the existence
of what's going on but devolves into a
rant about how we edit everything
anyways and we always try to present a
better version of ourselves this takes
us right into a conversation over the
phone between whiterose and Phillip
price White Rose is applying makeup and
it's notable that she uses her male
voice while talking to price but
switches to the feminine one when he
talked when she talks to her partner
there's so much information that comes
out in the short scene that its own
too much to go into without donning like
a full-on tinfoil hat but basically it
starts off with white rose asking him
why he would put so much faith in her
a woman who we assume must be Angela
because of the fact that that's the
person that he has regular interaction
with the only other candidate would be
Darlene but White Rose actually has more
access to get to her through Cisco so I
doubt that price would be mentioning
that or even really knows who Darlene is
White Rose is impatient for whatever
they are plotting to come together and
price reminds her that he is taking care
of things but it will take time the
burning of Rome is mentioned again then
this could be an indication that price
was behind the events of the hack all
along but under closer inspection the
theory doesn't really pass muster
because it's much more likely that price
is doing what powerful people often do
in times of uncertainty unrest they
profit and they use the situation to
make changes that increase their power
there is mention of the president and
the UN and a plant that can't be shut
down and this I think is pretty telling
about why they're working together but
it's not really clear what it is and I
can't get completely into the history of
like finance and what happened after
World War one and how that affected
things in the American banking system in
this video because it would just be a
whole another video on its own but it is
kind of possible that the last episode
where we saw that assassination of
Ferdinand that he has hanging in his
office if that might be a pretty good
clue as to what this Allegiance between
the dark army and II Corp is all about
whiterose hangs up when price says
things will take time and talks with her
part she mentions an equine strategy and
asks how long their stage two will take
we find out it's going to be six months
minimum and that White Rose is gonna
have to be patient which she obviously
doesn't like the equine strategy is a
little hard to speculate on but I think
it makes a lot of sense that if the
dollars destroyed due to the to the hack
cryptocurrency would be a very
profitable Enterprise plus we know that
Ray is involved in Bitcoin for some
reason or another and we also caught a
glimpse of this shot of an equine and
Bitcoin sign next to each other in Dom's
first scene her partner also shows her a
classified FBI report from Dom about
finding the arcade it wasn't sent by DOM
it was just they came across it one way
or the other when he zoo zoo man it
doesn't have much more information than
we already know but White Rose tells us
partner to look into it and find out
what they know Joanna has made her way
into Scott Knowles apartment and she
wants Tyrells severance package Knowles
is pounding wine and says he wants to
find the person who killed his wife she
offers to help him out by testifying in
a way that will help expose Tyrell 'as
to kill her but null stands firm and
says that her baby deserves and nothing
so Arlene is getting off the subway and
we see that her paranoia is getting
worse she sees men following her and we
don't know if they're real or not
as she's walking Cisco bumps into her
wearing one of the ooze huazi mask and
grabs her phone and destroys it he then
tells her to meet her up meet him up the
street at a bar they sit down at a place
called the looking glass which is a
namahage to Alice in Wonderland and he
tells her that the FBI found the arcade
he says the dark army wasn't behind the
killing of Romero as far as he knows and
they end up having sex in the bathroom
when they finish up he tells her there's
more there's a secret surveillance
project called Operation Berenstein and
that he doesn't know if they know who
they are or not he tells her neat she
needs to stop being a hard-ass and just
let him help her as a sidebar here
Berenstein is a word connected to an
alternate reality theater theory that
popped up online in the past men in a
couple years Google the Mandela effect
if you really if you want to read about
it it's definitely tripped out if you
have some time to kill Leon and Elliot
are back at the diner and it seems like
Leon has finished up a Seinfeld you
notice Elliot he notices Elliot is
preoccupied with the chessboard on the
table and asked him if he wants to play
this leads to this sort of philosophical
discussion where he asked Elliot if he
dreamed Leon asked what the game is for
as in if it isn't who you were playing
that is important then why are you
playing it's not that who it's the why
he finds out that a lady is playing for
his existence he asked him from that he
asked him if he really wants to be here
and saying right now and not in the
physical sense but in the cosmic sense
Lea Leon talks about existence and how
it can be good or bad and that's
basically up for up to us he also makes
a point that you have to find out the
future you were fighting for when Elliot
asked him you know how does he know if
he wants to be here or not it's Joey
badass his first really good serious
scene I mean obviously the sign
scenes were hilarious but it just kind
of leaves me wondering more like how did
Elliot come to know this guy in the
first place
I haven't seen really any good theories
about where Leone came from most of them
are pretty far-fetched Oh hopefully
we'll be able to find out where he came
from and you know where his storyline is
going in the future episodes because
he's you know he's he's definitely with
Elliot all the time so he has a unique
point of view
and it's definitely possible that he's
known Elliot for a long time even if he
doesn't know what he's been up to you
know with the hack and everything else
Elliot seems genuinely perplexed by this
idea and it changes the way he looks at
the idea of taking on mr. robot in the
game we give another joana scene where
we find out that she actually has
feelings for the boy - toy type we met
in a couple episodes back she says he
will never be able to give her anything
that she wants in life but somehow that
this is the reason why she loves him
then we cut straight to Elliot in bed
thinking about what his dream would be
it's a raising Arizona as scene where we
envision the future he imagines and it's
a very uh nelly 'it kind of future but i
guess i would say that it's a gun elliot
in a good way the sequence is really
interesting because before this it's
hard to know if these are the kinds of
things Elliot once or not to be able to
show affection to those who cares about
to see them happy on a certain level all
people want those things but he lays out
he lays them out pretty clearly and
there isn't much doubt at least not in
the dream the things he dreams of aren't
about himself
they're about their well they're more
like solutions to a socially awkward
nature he talks about being what most
people would consider normal in the way
he interacts with the people that are
close to him I guess there is hope in it
which is which would be what he needs at
this point I mean it's not overly
complex or unrealistic it's something
that you can work towards and something
that he could play for something human
that exists in real life like in the
real world away from the keyboard so it
it's it's an effective scene I like the
overlay of the music and I like the way
that he sort of sorts through the
different parts of it as he goes also
other than the the building fallen in
the background I mean there's nothing
that is reflective of what they were
trying to do necessarily with the hack
either it's all human
and it's all people that you know we
already know not the effects of culture
or society so let me know in the
comments what you think is this the kind
of stuff that you thought that he was
gonna come up with or do you think this
was a little bit out of left field one
of the first things that stands out
about that is that he hugs back in the
last part when he's talking about amends
which is weird since he we know he
doesn't like being touched and we see
this full shot at the table at the end
with most of the people we've seen him
interact with obviously your Romero and
Gideon aren't there for good reason but
it also makes some sense that we don't
see mr. robotic Krista at the table
either there is a seat reserved for us
though which is nice
and QWERTY the fish is on the table but
as much as I was expecting yet we didn't
see flipper show up at the end we see
the Ecore building fall in the
background while everyone at the table
cheers in bed Elliot realizes this is
the future he always wanted and he would
very much like to fight for the chess
match begins and we find out that I
think well but what I think we already
all knew there is no winner
after the third stalemate which Elliott
points out to us is statistically
impossible it becomes clear that neither
side could win out over the other mr.
robot says it's a sign that he's there
for a reason but Elliott isn't ready to
buy into that yet we see Angela
approached price to make a little power
play she wants a her boss's job in a
better office she feels like she
deserves all this because she found a
pattern that exposes what price is
actually after she thinks that they
don't want a third party to inspect the
Washington Township plant she has some
influence over what they do in the
class-action suit so she figures she
could make this happen and get what get
that other stuff as a reward he says
that she's impressive while at the same
time saying that this is all in her head
he makes mention that it's always good
to dream and or have dreams but at the
same time never says that she's wrong
next we see LEDs on the phone again and
this time Darlene is begging him for
help she tells him they might be owned
and that she needs him to get on our
seat he says he doesn't have access and
she tells him to figure it out before
the conversation ends he asked her if
she was serious about misting mr. robot
instead of him and she says that she
only needs Elliot he heads over to Ray's
and decides to help him out with his
computer problem so that he can end up
getting online ray is pleasantly
surprised that he changed his mind and
sets him up to get started before he
hands over the keyboard though he tell
Eliott about profits that also heard
voices and says that it could be
divinity if he lets it right gives him a
folder from the old IT guy and Elliott
says he'll be able to do the migration
ray tells him that his online online
business is really important to him and
that he's a private guy he stresses that
he needs only to not look anywhere he
doesn't need to he also has the guy who
acted as his muscle when we saw him
before come in to watch him as he works
all this doesn't look good but Elliott
decides to go ahead because of Darlene
not unsurprisingly as soon as he gets on
the computer he contacts Darlene and she
lays out the fact that there's an
operation that Romero dies we talk about
Berenstain earlier and that they found
the arcade so not new information for us
but new information for Elliott then he
you know he basically goes through the
thing that he needs to you know protect
his sister her sisters in trouble
they're getting closed in on and he
pulls up this article about them
changing from blackberry to Android and
then he you know mr. robot asked him
what he's doing he says he's gonna hack
the FBI so pretty
pretty straightforward but a cool scene
I'll you know just the same so there we
have another strong ending to another
strong episode a couple of Easter eggs
to point out you can watch you can
actually watch the careful massacre of
the bourgeoisie on the USA Network's
website and if you type in the IP
address that you see Elliott added put
into the IRC there it'll connect you to
what looks like the gentlemen Channel
type in the exact same things Darlene
did and Elliott's response will have
another line added to it at the end that
you see on the screen I didn't come up
with it myself I saw it on reddit but
and I don't actually want to give away
what it says but it goes along with the
closing scene and like it doesn't give
away some big secret it just it's just
kind of cool that they set that up and
you can actually do that not sure if
there's anything else you can do on
there like if typing different commands
or not but I thought that was pretty
cool
overall I would say they moved away from
the idea of loneliness some to the idea
of dreams
so perhaps dreams and what you know a
person is willing to fight for is what
the answer to Elliott's problem will be
or maybe it's just another part of the
journey on the way I was a little bit
bummed we didn't get more dom stuff in
this episode but
the white roasting definitely made up
for it and I'm sure that there'll be a
lot of dumb stuff in the next episode I
think it's a little early to tell
exactly what prices plans are I mean I
think it's pretty obvious that it has
something to do with the power play that
involves currency some sort of way that
you know he's gonna be in a much
stronger position than he was before the
hack but it's hard to say who's gonna
end up on top and if everything's gonna
work out and exactly what will be won at
the end of the day one thing's for sure
though for now it seems that eff society
streamin making the world a better place
is definitely nowhere near playing out
how they wanted it to once again I'm in
on just how much you know the director
producer writer showrunner Sam s mail
packs into each episode these extra
lapis ODEs are awesome and the amount of
Easter eggs is just way over the top the
show is interactive like on a different
level than anything I can think of and
if there wasn't so much going on story
wise I would spend a lot more time
talking about some of those things
who knows maybe in the future if these
episode videos pick up a little bit as
far as people watching them I'll think
about doing extra bonus videos during
the week so let me know what you think
in the comments about the episode what
do you think price and white rows are up
to do you think angela is getting played
or if she's actually holding her own
also do you think ray do you think he's
a good guy do you think Elliot can trust
him or do you think he there's more to
his character under the surface that we
haven't seen come out yet please like
the video and subscribe to my channel I
really enjoy doing these episode
breakdowns and I want to continue in
that support really helps out thanks for
watching I'll talk to you soon